ah les belles lundi vers 9h50 le matin
sur france 3 centre val de loire puisque
je vais rejoindre gérard jugnot pour son
film que vous voyez c'est beau la vie
quand on y pense bonjour gerra merci
d'être avec nous et merci maker surtout
devant cette renault 8 gordini instar de
votre fils puisque vous interpréter le
rôle d'un ancien pilote de rallye non en
bretagne votre fils décès dans un
accident et son coeur et donner un autre
enfant interprété par françois des blocs
hugo l'éloigné encore c'est celui de mon
fils ça c'est pas bon pour la salle et a
besoin d'être génial maintenant la
raison que sa mère tu fais des conneries
tu fais des cascades avec des trucs un
volume tu bois tu avais un tollé en inde
pour rentrer cette nuit un peu raté sa
vie quoi il était raté son mariage raté
un peu sa carrière et son fils aussi il
n'a pas vraiment connu et candide il
paraît que ya ce cadeau de coeur il va
avoir l'idée un peu folle de retrouver
et va tomber sur deux blocs à jeunes
acteurs sont formidables qui l'a le
cadeau et qui est totalement
incontrôlable qui convoie cap a vécu il
vous l'a eu peur de pas se réveiller
maintenant il veut puissant norme est
arrivé rouler à 200 mais moi je vais ces
bleus de le calmer mais lui
parallèlement il va essayer aussi dom
tom vont mettre sur les rails vous et
moi je suis un peu comme dans ma voiture
quand je mets dans mon parking avec 1,4
à l'est sur quatre tartes un rôle plus à
prendre n'importe quoi tvp
et pas de centre là pour mettre des
pièces
vous êtes à facilite voiture ou non gm
en mer c'est l'âme facile beaucoup je la
trouve arrêter quoi finalement c'était
une mise en valeur de la tradition du
savoir faire français autour des
automobiles que l'on aime tous pardon de
bourg mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
important de donc il ya des objets comme
c'est un formidable sûr intéressant
comme comme quand j'étais coiffeur ou la
gordie rigolo c'est sûr qui est rigolote
en même temps que qui toute une année
toute une époque
j'ai ici quand j'ai besoin de réfléchir
à faire passer je sais c'est un
contre-temps vous avez 40 de mot pour
parler de la pluie c'est toi qui tombe
et on voit beaucoup de clichés breton le
kouign amann aussi les cirés la coiffe
sur la belle crêpière les danse et la
musique folklorique et cela contraste
avec l'ambiance méditerranéenne à de
toulon autres lieux de tournage quelle
est l effet recherché une opposition
finalement une position et puis il
fallait trouver un truc un peu heureux
un peu urbas toulon mais en même temps
et avec cette très très beau là toute la
région et il arrivait on a tous plus
rurales peu océanique mais proposer la
mi-temps année l'atlantique les marées
la mer qui bouge pas s'amuser puis en
bretagne il ya des fondamentaux c'est
pas des clichés c'est les fondamentaux
pour tous bien qu'ils s'impliquent
d'entre vous c'est à rien pas ça leur
ferait on aura avancé
tu rattrapera jamais le temps perdu et a
tout raté ta vie ton fils
ouais
c'est ce que tu penses à ton fils
non
est ce que ce film c'est une ode à la
vie à ce qu'elle nous apporte de plus
beau c'est à dire les changes le partage
avec les hommes
aulas m'a dit oui lancé oui c'est un
film droits humains c'est un film pour
qui fait du bien c'est vrai que sa part
dans le noir un peu comme tall estime
que je fais comme monsieur batignole une
époque
et puis on va vers le soleil c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi ce titre chanson lui
qui a trouvé un peu solaire comme ça
pour les gens disent en sortant ça m'a
fait du bien ça film qui fait du bien
donc je suis content quoi on se régale
oui on se régale c'est notre onzième
réalisation et vous aviez abordé dans
d'autres films des thèmes dramatiques
comme le chômage l'occupation de la
france en 1942 où la guerre civile dans
les balkans cette fois donc vous a
intéressé sans que ce soit évidemment le
sujet du film au don d'organes et de
greffe c'est un thème qui vous fascine
oui c'est vrai je prends des sujets qui
me font peur qui m'interpelle qui
m'interroge et sachent tout ça c'est
formidable ça ne croisez quelqu'un qui
avait à rentrer comme ça depuis l'âge de
6 ans ce type là y vit grâce à malheur
c'est ça qui est fou c'est ses principes
de la comédie et quoi on comprend du
malheur et ont fait de la vie et balla
c'est ce à quoi il ya un malheur mais
c'est un malheur qui va permettre à
plein de gens de continuer leur vie quoi
merci d'avoir été avec nous versions à
orléans et en région centre val de loire
pour la matinale 9h50 le matin sur
france 3